Samsung Galaxy has been at the top of
the ltk standings for the entire 2017
summer split so in honor of their
success so far we put together the best
of Samsung Galaxy this season and with
being a team effort here Nikki all
danced the flash okay crank it out of
the way guys by blood goes to crown
disaster for Mickey I want you to get a
kickback on the crown Oh bit late on the
flat seventh crown it's going to turn
that one around brilliant equalize if it
isn't enough it is certainly not many
ways that is still going to be the desk
of the tart Kade give me an optic
thought kill running forward and Linda
Ron that was an embarrassing placement
of the flames bitter too easy kills the
last Nexus turret is going to be alive
for approximately half a second and the
Nexus will follow the same way we're
going to Game three samsung even it out
against the rocks Tigers very own
pedestal yet very early on in the bodies
dangerous core JJ playing off to the
side does have to strangle cause down
already
and look at the AoE this is disgusting
from Samsung's on you just couldn't get
any damage and that's four for one in
favor of samsung galaxy dress the
training goes th big engage not quite
sure they can get enough from their
teammate taking up most of the damages
the arrow is going to connect right on
top of Mickey may be the first one to
fall down Linder on tries to beat them
out but not going to happen ki he's
going to fall off to the back end and
ambition gets the flow gets the leap and
it's also easy because QA says well I
want to tank the turret I want to do
anything here because I just want to
have fun and finish off this game off
your crown that damage is repugnant but
it's core JJ that does the finishing
blow
that's the Nexus falling in samsung
after a rough game one turn it all
around the next two so chrono cross
record here on to faker
over the wall comes ham Bishop doesn't
have a clue but doesn't matter the
damage is there they come down for first
blood
I'm not quite going to connect their
toys a grasping root chip okay and crown
just comes up with the kill almost has
the double trying to get on top of
fingers and so much damage with the
cleave coming out
I'm going back in the root landing in on
the bank we're not worried about the
coefficient plus I'm finished it now
expose 30 minutes and Wolff rejoining
can they do anything to turn this one
around chocolate comes out but a too
little too late the damage is done
Samsung 30 minute victory over SK really
nice walking up again backgrounds coming
through you're from QA he's flashing
with the wall now to a blasting plan
could come back through this is the most
action you can have a hobo jumping in
you're not going home does it have a
question over the wall could be first
plug going under kind of hoodie flashing
away azimuth and then our backpack you
BAE jumps over the walls locked in on
the bank penis here five still no five
peers here comes here I don't even need
the ultimatum flashes forward to do that
final hit in enough peanut mad spot
limestone is available ambition pops an
awesome self away since I'm still on the
chase dumb comes through and hard to
Baker they leave it with a wall ultimate
now use the lock them up the shield come
down but there's nothing more than he
can do no Baker all day be pushing
forward lands the one rocking for the
slow and I wolf is just about here for
the tether you'll be able to lock him
down Cuba can he make it out of here
alive from wolves it's not in the
airport wolf denying they leap over the
walls you may still goes love it up
crowd arriving head around on his head
takes down hoody unleash power down on
the bank who still desperately trying to
kite back looks like he might kill to
stay alive at least for the moment GP
being burned out here by Baker a double
kill over to ground and peanut goes down
under Samsung 420 blaze it for Samsung
Galaxy they win the game they win 2-0
China room into me along with poor JJ
looks like you may want to dive we look
at the kill there's the tidal wave and
he don't stop it as you have some oh
there it is the double flash on and
there's the slicing Maelstrom trying to
treat a kill here QA will flash away
Marn should be able to finish this off
but he goes on the run doesn't have his
cooldown so that is going to be Prive
escaping don't let the Sun on cam Bishop
there's to knock up very thank you but
it goes looks like he actually he gets
the way alive but picture
gonna be able to burst out scary make
them totally unavailable about
and another kill going over to ambition
Perot all by his lonesome will
eventually be picking out for it crying
and Evans to take out ambition but they
just cannot the Sun is going to be
followed up there nicely done
Sampson we big great response they take
out three he's still not sure why he's
here for them being through buzz he's
really thank you for all the friends and
always appreciate all the love and
support judge coming through from the
back side to you they going in efficient
way to go over the wall 2,000 HP on that
Baroness wage rule it's the body plant
won't be able to come up with this GOP
on bikes it away a few majors wreaking
havoc on to a TD but it gets knocked off
a score goes wall has to retreat the
meantime Cataclysm comes down in on top
of a [ __ ] massive Todd comes in from
actually still pay for it with his life
is core JJ scoops up the kill Cooper
zero so far from Samsung looking for
more what the naívi Baird box from
coming through now Bowen gets himself
back once that shadow to be pumped
they income cube a pause and down
amazing prediction by ambition with the
explosive calm I'm going to stand behind
a minion get down the way that one but
it's good stretching strike and the less
bounces there as well depth trying to
dance out of the way just not going to
be enough but double kill for ambition
and then the flashy get himself out of
the engagement now cube a path to do the
same thing steps in here and now wants
to sign up a big battle and mission
doing so much work and it's a great
cocoon to break up this battle but Smith
already dead
the cat did gravity field from porn does
a bunch of weapon he's knocked up now
and rule up he's starting to get the
work done kept trying to dance this one
out does he have to Rend available
though he gets turned into a little
critter and will get taken down QA comes
back and Samsung this is what we're
expecting in Game one grand entrance
comes in on the core JJ they're actually
looking for more gore JJ has absolutely
nowhere that he can go rule or
eventually turns up Brendan heroic
entrance comes in as well and there's
the flash barrel completely unbounded
portuguese of dance must explain without
going on okay you'll get out with an
inquire we're going to be if there's a
baron left all i'm bishop can do its try
to buy some time stop the recall but the
damage
kaitlin's hammering away at the base and
there's nobody that can do anything
about it they're trying to burst them
down can't actually see right now looks
like ruler is still alive and here we go
we're back and alive
finally and coming in here as helper he
takes out the Caitlyn but look at the
Nexus does not matter samsung pinky
number one for all by themselves trying
to trade in here actually a quickly
we're going down so much accent help or
trying to go in but it looks like rulers
although with the help of crowd crazy
it's going to slice and dice his way out
the bear trap is going to land on two
crazy
lots of damage coming in and that's
going to be the shockwave the dissonance
picks up the kill and now blessed he's
in trouble this is the warrior rex i
remember he's going to get blown up as
temp makes his way through wants to be
able to get to trade but almost survives
but doesn't the flash out from ambition
he's looking for the cue that it's going
to be cube a that helps with the damage
they're going to land it here the
question you can see there is the taint
of corruption into the knock-up where's
the burst damage and see a little bit
leap to get there now ambition making
his way in he does have that cast
there's a flash body slam into the
exhaust going to be an easy kill for
samson to pick up here oh see flashing
away gets locked up by that son look at
how much damage crown does right now to
this guy and so on he's trying to be a
hero get blocked up against that wall
follow up here from crown looking for
the double cylinder son and there it is
that's going to be triple actually going
over two crowns about this ur playing
very patiently the big body slam on
takes to does qss but does get devoured
without doing much to re-engage with the
big body slam on to cruise on down he
goes and that's to be the end of this
one here h2 getting pulled out Teddy
trying to be a hero by himself and he
will get devoured by Snow Flower but
there's the stun and Samsung trying to
take out an inhibitor alternatives are
now down who they looking to go for that
TP on in this will be the last two
turrets
trying to look for that kill on MC but
here we go looks like Samsung able to
take game number three will take a
couple of kills on their way out and
Down Goes the Nexus 1 welcome through
duck on is it a danger has to get dark
passage of the era or will not connect
efficient custody for the spikes going
to be
from God take that one away inefficient
goes down hanging on to zero so far you
may look upon it double kill coming
through triple kill over at a cube a
Kenny find more breaking block dead
won't be able to get the Quadra crueler
tons them up as the nomina softening
down a happy to be picking up today
actually is vicious what all the Sun
comes through now caught at the high
tail at around if it pick it out yes
that's 50 the turn around here where the
side of Samsung nose coming through
three dead four Long's you poor as
gorilla is now the last one it's another
triple kill for kube a Yamini dies with
this ultimate up they can't find that's
what they want more work you babe yeah
qubit your core jjq baby is almost isaac
so just combining them they're working
so well together decent I'll copy this
the weave is wool oh my still prison
there at the same time bang is going to
get taken down to faith goal is nice the
crown is easily going to pick up that
kill not allow any more of these catches
weave is well now going to be invested
bank moves himself to the correct well
there's no it's called they going to
turn it all the way around and crowd is
going to get obliterated they've traded
one for one those wolf would sacrifice
in this fight could learn and comes in
because I love damage now as blank is
going to fall down as well an ambition
still survives bang trying to cut this
one out but doesn't get to kill it and
wait for the Baron and heard he's
actually going to complete it chokes
back tears more damage coming in but you
may find his way into the bellows ideas
from faker as the fates call does come
in banks still doing a lot of work with
make up already dead honey trying to
find QB but oh my god crown is just
going to poop him over the wall picked
on our bank he's locked back as well but
look at the health bars on Samsung bang
might have an opportunity yes let me
cover wolf he's got both Bank Falls as
well and it's now only blank there but
The Weavers wall that's going to catch
out the cute little wreck site and he's
now going to ball at the same time that
is going to eventually be the wipe the
ACE and Samsung Galaxy moving it up the
middle a tunnel himself out of the way
so they are going to give up the Baron
now they're looking for Cuba he's going
to be taken now a 5 vs. 4 is SKT jump it
over the top can actually get the work
done attorney launches in the back like
great quickness from whoopin
well as little a once again guiding this
one Audi to come get incredibly good at
tithing and they are going to pick that
one up it is going to be blank falling
eventually and they just could not kill
the Baris crown just turns up at exactly
the right time they're trying to [ __ ]
you max is blank he can't find the cue
and he's being slowed down there are the
pebbles once again and he gets another
hook shot
and now blank just at the mercy of Brown
throwing down the thread and holster
that's going to be a cue major steps his
way forward and grabs the kill under
blank let's find themselves an agro
blank looking for the hero play but he
just doesn't get it he's going to be
taken down qv5 Kearney just wants to get
himself in the middle of the fight and
bang it's just going to explore now wolf
after flash and who needs in no man's
land
Baron up super creeps and smacking on
the Nexus Tony wants to point one pick
on a ground even going to survive and
it's a triple kill for ambition he
wanted the Penta but the nexus dies
first
and another 2 0 for Samsung Galaxy and
some before 0 over SKT and parked
themselves in first spot your MVP will
be ambition look at that score seven
zero and seven in Game one he took a lot
of time to get online he was caught and
his jungle and we thought
I don't know ambition I don't know about
your choice to go for the sejuani but in
this game just like crown it was very
often where I needed it's kind of
surprising to us for most of the part we
didn't think that we would get a 2-0
victory so I'm very proud of our team
and that was the best of samsung galaxy
so far in the 2017 lck summer split
what's your favorite Samsung Galaxy
moment let us know in the comments below
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button